when the pandemic hits some wealthier
school districts have few problems
converting to remote instruction most of
their students had computer hardware an
internet connection and other vital
resources but other schools had to
scramble and quickly find ways to
continue to serve their students or we
have everywhere al has the story today
particularly was emotional being in the
classroom the end of the day it's more
about I feel relationships and just I'm
very passionate about what I do
Cindy Rhea's teaches second grade at the
Como Leadership Academy in Fort Worth
Texas that's the hardest part about this
internet connection
availability these are only eight I have
22 we visited Como elementary in the
fall last year 91 percent of the
school's population is african-american
or Latino 94% of these students are
economically disadvantaged and more than
half are at risk is there any doubt in
your mind that a majority of your
parents were probably having to work
during this pandemic absolutely
everybody's priority right now is making
sure to keep a roof over their head
feeding their children and still trying
to navigate the world of teaching and
learning
principal Valencia Rhines push to get
150 Chromebooks and 11 Internet hotspots
to families in need and grading has
changed to a pass/fail system to keep
kids engaged teachers make regular home
visits Victor Martinez stays with his
mother while his dad continues to work
his construction job today
we have teachers videotaping themselves
actually teaching lessons in posting
that that's not required is it
absolutely not and so to just be able to
see my staff and all of us step up to
meet the knees where we are it's been
what keeps me going for CBS this morning
Saturday media vol Fort Worth Texas